[Musique]
et représentants de l'état de justice du
chu et du samu ont visité la nouvelle
plateforme téléphonique capelle commune
entre le 10 et le samu
objectif favoriser améliorer la réponse
à apporter aux secours d'urgence
alors ici nous sommes dans le ctr donc
sans traitement valeur principalement
nous répondait au 18 donc il densifie
l'appel pendant six ans ça nécessite
l'engagement des pompiers ou
basculer le requérant sur les
partenaires tels que le samu ou la
police ou divers services
avec cette plateforme inauguré le 14
juin dernier dans un bâtiment du chu à
bellepierre la réunion apparaît dans le
peloton de tête des départements de
france en matière de dispositifs
d'urgence deux opérateurs sur un même
territoire pas des missions de service
public de sécurité aux personnes eh bien
il fallait trouver une bonne
coordination cela a pris du temps
cela représente un coût bien sûr
important mais là le département a
apporté et bien ce budget qu'on sent que
la réalisation de ce projet est
aujourd'hui parce que nous visitons
sevel salles équipées ici au chr de
bellepierre nous sommes fiers de voir
que le partenariat existe et que enfin
la réunion dispose d'un centre
opérationnel mode et âme pour intervenir
en amont lorsqu'il ya une crise cette
plateforme s'inscrit dans la volonté du
gouvernement d'améliorer la qualité de
soin de prise en charge des patients
cette co localisation elle permet de
rendre cohérentes les procédures de se
coordonner parce que finalement ici on a
réuni les deux grands services de
secours aux personnes ceux qui
enregistrent
les appels ce qui engage les moyens ce
qui coordonne les renforts et ça c'est
le quotidien du samu ans le quotidien
des sapeurs pompiers c'est vraiment une
plus value de pouvoir le faire ensemble
d'entendre finalement ce qui est gérée
par par son voisin de pouvoir se
coordonner de mieux appréhender aussi
les renforts qui peuvent intervenir
entre le 10 et le salut le département a
financé la mise en place de cette
structure opérationnelle à hauteur de 10
millions d'euros
[Musique]